hey guys I'm a beach art welcome to
Abby's kitchen today I partner with my
friends at my who sponsored this video
help you eat and love your vegetables as
a dietitian I spent a lot of my day
talking about things like fiber mindful
eating and of course eating your
vegetables and I get it I know a lot of
you and probably your kids are way more
excited about eating cake than you are
carrot but that's because sometimes
those vegetables don't taste so good
so stop boiling your vegetables to death
and actually add in lots of flavors so
you can get excited about eating them I
love you think my honey Dijon mustard in
my vegetable recipes because it adds a
huge hit of flavor for only 15 calories
a teaspoon and virtually no fat
especially compared to a lot of the
other vegetable vehicles out there like
Mayo plus it is way more versatile than
a lot of condiments like ketchup but it
still has that little bit of sweetness
to entice the P palette so I've got
three awesome honey dijon mustard hacks
help you and your kids fall in love with
spring vegetables
let's do first up my honey mustard
yogurt dip in a bowl I mix together some
plain Greek yogurt from my honey dijon
mustard and the juice of half a lemon
mix it together and serve with your
favorite veggies for dipping
next my honey mustard roasted radishes I
spread my radishes out onto a baking
sheet and toss them with olive oil salt
and pepper then roast them at 400
degrees for about 20 minutes stirring
once to ensure that they Brown easily
then remove them from the oven toss them
with my honey dijon mustard then return
them to get cookie and caramelize for
another 5 minutes transfer to a serving
platter and garnish with hazelnuts
and finally my honey mustard spring
pasta salad first I cook a box of coal
grain pasta according to the box
instructions but in the last two minutes
I add in the asparagus and peas for the
pot then in a small bowl I mix together
some extra virgin olive oil fresh lemon
juice my honey Dijon mustard and a pinch
of salt pepper to taste and now it's
time to assemble in a large bowl I'm
scared the cooked pasta asparagus and
peas with some spinach cooks chicken
breasts strawberries watermelon radish
avocado feta cheese and the dressing
toss it all together and enjoy so guys I
hope you enjoyed these awesome honey
dijon mustard hacks to help you eat more
vegetables if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
some of your favorite ways to eat
vegetables subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
you